I've now spent about 60 hours in
one-on-one conversations of the Dalai
Lama it's a real gift because he's a
very very interesting man he's very
bright and he loves to argue with out
rancor I love to argue without rancor
also it's over those six years of
conversation that he has shifted some of
my interests into compassion my interest
has now become on what I call global
compassion where you feel compassion not
just for members of your family not just
for people who are the same skin color
not just for people who speak the same
language but for all human beings and
your wish is to reduce the suffering of
all human beings on this planet
regrettably that's rare and yet I
believe that survival of the world
requires that we get a lot more global
compassion is global compassion and some
people do have it is that a gift like
being a great athlete or a great
musician we don't say why can't everyone
be Beethoven or Paul McCartney we know
that only some people have that gift is
that what global compassion is a gift or
is it within all of us but it's only
been awakened in some of us there are
some Buddhist meditative practices that
are designed to increase compassion
their hard work and they don't work with
everyone I'm looking for other ways
although there are now a few hundred
scientists studying compassion very few
of them are studying how to bring about
more global compile
and that's what we need